top five documentary films that every
aspiring filmmaker should watch
wow i'm gonna make a few friends with
this list and a lot of enemies
um just because i know a lot of these
filmmakers um
we could do the top 100 later we'll get
that
i think for people who are interested in
in in making documentary films or
working
working in documentaries um i mean this
is completely subjective
but the films that i go back to all the
time and that are that really inspire me
no matter
no matter how many times i've seen them
um
i let's see i loved um
i really loved the civil war by ken
burns and i met him
when that film was released back in 1991
right when it was broadcast on pbs i met
him at a screening
and saw one of the episodes one of the
one of the one of the
acts of that film i think it was like an
hour long
um and that was amazing
um the civil war is it's either 9 or 13
hours long i mean it's a long film
but each episode sort of almost stands
alone
so i would really watch that and see
what he did
with a story
where none of the subjects are alive
anymore um
most of those stories have sort of died
in some way
or have been passed on several times and
what he did with that film is really
a landmark achievement
i loved hoop dreams um
still do i'm from chicago that's where
they made that film
i was starting my career in chicago as
they were making that film
and i actually was at their production
headquarters kartemquin's headquarters
uh one day while they were in production
and saw
all of the tapes that they were shooting
to make that film there were like 800
tapes in a room about this big
you know floor to ceiling all labeled
with the dates on the side i mean it was
just like horrifying
it was just like what is this and my
friend's like this is my there's a movie
called hoop dreams
that's gonna be great you know i that
it's it's an amazing film but also i
think
it sort of feels like home that's where
i grew up um
so i love that um i love the fog of war
i love errol morris's film the fog of
war
he sat down robert mcnamara for about
four days
and did about 12 hours worth of
interviews with him
and he caught robert mcnamara who was
the
secretary of defense during the vietnam
war
he caught robert mcnamara at a moment in
his life where i think he sort of wanted
to
just be honest and and lay all his cards
on the table
sort of a mia culpa
and it's really a study in in
interviewing
how to interview people really well so i
i just love that film
i think man on wire was terrific and i
liked that they
um relied really heavily on recreations
which i didn't really love that much
i i um i think i i was sort of resistant
to recreations within documentary films
um and um
and yet james did just an
unbelievable job doing recreations that
sort of fit very elegantly with the
archival footage
it's just a great great movie it's also
funny because
it's one of those rare films where
you know the ending you know the ending
when you start watching the film the
ending is on the poster
i mean it's it's
i don't want to give anything away but i
mean
you know where the movie's going and yet
it's a wonderful ride so i just love
that
and then the final film
you know i love this movie called the
invisible war
which is done by uh kirby dick who
doesn't live very far from here
our friend doug blush uh and and derek
boonstra both friends of ours edited
that film
um nominated for academy award in 2013.
what i love about that film it's a great
story
it's about a very difficult subject
which is rape in the military
and how the military handles these cases
or really mishandles these cases
and what i love about that film is that
it's
really a study in the impact of
storytelling the impact of documentary
films
i mean kirby and doug and derek and
their team
of about five or six people made their
film
about a mile from here in a small house
i mean talk about a small tiny little
band of
of david's if you will and the bad guy
in this film is the us military
the most powerful organization on the
planet by far
and they took them down um
they told a story a beautiful story
beautiful and very heartbreaking story
about women and men who had been
sexually abused
in the military and the the
the um sort of
mistreatment that they got the injustice
that they got in return
when they tried to blow the whistle on
what had happened to them
and so they make this film they get
accepted to sundance
it screens at sundance it becomes this
sensation
this movie that everyone needs to see
and then
something really unbelievable happened
which is leon panetta the secretary of
defense
at the time saw the film on air force
one
they landed he called a press conference
and he said i've just seen a film
called the invisible war and we are
going to start doing things differently
in our military this cannot go on
any further and they've made great
strides they could probably do more
hopefully they will but they really
change the way that they investigate
these kinds of cases
they change the way that they punish
these criminals
who are sexually abusing people in their
own ranks
that's the power of filmmaking it's the
power of
really good documentary filmmaking and
i think that's a good number five for us
you